これはローソンで見つけましたカレー飛騨路
ガン2弾ツアー毎月6
いつ発売ん
長いそうでローソンで売ってました
カレーと左の創立的な出会いってことでも本当に今日は酢酒ませんよ
なんか真剣に不思議だと思って買ったんですよだってカレーと稲荷ってもうねぇ
民団の組み合わせあっじゃいけない禁断の果実 other の小指みたいな感じです
か
です
さあ皆さんも普通にこのレビューはていないと思うんで
今日ふざけませんよラン2てなんですかね
ダーン中だねぇ
今日はこの緞通のかバレたりは食べるじゃん
開けるんじゃ
カラーる鳥だサーん入った草木はふざけないん
こんなんですよ
レイドに何か僕になりは好きなんですけどカレーは甘口しか食べれないんですよ
番号逃れの甘口が一番好き
か
まだだ
なかなかに彼が入っ
金井これ
辛い辛い
これからいうから行かない誰これ辛いの苦手ですもう
からだーつーの軽い台は少しからいいので a
みんな気をつけて誰じゃなぁ
辛い数
わざと断面を知らないかよ
いないというカレーのクオリティが高いんで
この組み合わせは大将みたいな
なんかこう
akira と結婚する前から私たち続かないわみたいな感じじゃないんで
まあ比較的高結婚せからもうすぐエルナー
結婚生活が送れる気がします
受けたら買ってみてください
the
おまっ